interim let's send you all the way on
down-south 1,600 miles to scott hello
everyone you may have just seen a bird
fly through the thick undergrowth there
we were hoping it would stick her on
that so it's calling it say orange
breasted bush Shrike and it's been
lurking around yeah
doing some hunting so I'm hoping we are
going to be able to find it and show it
to you at some point they're quite
secretive birds and very beautiful
my name is Scott and it is wonderful to
welcome you down to South Africa we are
in the sabi sands it's a blazing hot
sunny afternoon and I'm teamed up with
Senzo on camera now I've got some
exciting updates from the morning for
those of you who went on the sunrise
Safari
there was a buck kill found this morning
hoisted up in a tree with no sir any
leopard in the area and we guess that it
was either one of two sisters shadow or
Tandy and we were hoping that it was
going to be Tandy that returned to the
kill and she did indeed return last we
were enjoying breakfast there was
another vehicle that was staking out
that area to make sure we found out
which leopard was responsible for it and
more importantly if it was Tandy that
she would hopefully lead us to her cub
thereafter once she had fit on the kill
a bit more maybe she would go back to
the den and interestingly for the third
time that we've noticed now she took the
kill down from the tree and towards the
den sites we know this because she took
the kill dial from the tree I thought
she was just moving it into a shady area
but she then kind of stopped it was very
thick she was seen somewhere just up to
our right but we actually saw her from
other side of the road from where we are
now from kind of a road we down in a
riverbed now and we got a tiny little
glimpse of the cub and then she
disappeared somewhere into these
thickets so we guessing that she's
stashing the cubs somewhere in and
around quite a few little gullies in
this area and lots of thick vegetation
so we've come here in the hope that she
will pop out again
that's what we are planning for our
afternoon doing a mistake this area I'll
sand with a little bit of luck
she will pop on to the scene with that
young cab
it's a tricky area this because it is so
thick we're not gonna be able to get the
vehicle exactly where we wants it but
that's testament what a good dinner it
is that it's kind of impenetrable since
I spotted the bird again look at that
what have you well then since one of the
most Austin Birds you've ever laid eyes
on oh cool you can see the way it's
holding open its beak that it confirms
that it's a hot afternoon even the birds
are panting well I'm very happy that we
got you that glimpse of the orange
breasted bush Michael here it is again
it's a bird we don't see very often so
let's try this wave for as long as
possible you can see it's definitely
hunting looking for a meal I can't
believe what good visuals we're getting
of it this is absolutely incredible it's
so close to us which is very unlike them
they're usually quite shy and secretive
and let's hope this is going to be the
kind of benchmark for the afternoon and
not only will we maybe get spoiled to
this incredible sighting but also with
the cub of tandy which is only about 6
or 7 weeks old now now that the bird is
flipped off a vehicle and she would like
to let you know what her plans are for
the afternoon
yes I am indeed another bird and I am a
bird that can drive thanks God hi
everyone good afternoon we had this
amazing mail water buck position so
beautifully and then this younger one
came up and out of the way so we'll
still take it young male water buck on
screen at the moment it is an
interesting afternoon we can hear some
thunder in the far distance I think in
the next two or three hours it's most
likely going to rain I don't think it's
gonna rain just at the moment and I'm
very excited that Scott's finding of
that steam will kill this morning did
result in Tandy that is absolutely
fantastic because we've been struggling
to find where she is and Scott and I
were just having a chat before we left
on Drive and we're thinking possibly
maybe she's not fully Denning anymore
but just sort of moving the cub to
wherever she makes kills which makes
quite a bit of sense she's not too far
from where we saw her on Christmas but
she's farther from where we thought she
was going to be after the sighting in
the rain that some of the other vehicles
had of her moving farther north so yeah
well done Scott so so exciting okay so I
am Noelle and this is Safari live as we
know you've met teyla you've met Ralph
and you've met Scott and on camera I
have furred he's so we've got so Fergus
thumbs up being and saluting and all of
that and don't forget we're live we're
interactive out of South Africa with
myself and Scott out of Kenya with Ralph
and teyla so our plans for this
afternoon is to eventually make it back
to where we had husana this morning the
little chief little prince of Juma I'm
just waiting for it to cool down a bit
it is really warm I would probably say
it's about 35 or 36 but yeah that's just
just to submit it's also very humid with
that Thunder shower moving through other
than that I think I really want some
elephants today so we checked twin dams
and we check the treehouse amazingly no
elephants but again elephants usually
rock up where the Thunder is before we
even hear the Thunder so they're
probably farther south and west of us at
the moment
ooh Julia what is my most memorable
moment as a safari live drive in 2017 on
goose Black Mamba siding with Senzo my
other was when tonne of those and then
Jean Dre and I had an amazing setting
with the sticks on twin dam wall and
then I have to say anything the Ferg and
I did during rehearsals live and not
like rehearsals where we were chasing
those wild dogs all completely epic and
amazing oh and that hippo sighting where
that other female was eating the
afterbirth from the other female that
that that gave birth to that little
hippo at Chitwood dam top ones that I
can think of now I have a very hard time
picking just one I was trying to pick
just ten photos from this past year that
I really liked and then I was going
through I was like oh but that sighting
was great so yeah I'm very bad at
narrowing that down but let's see maybe
the last Drive of 2017 allows us
something even more exciting we picked
out as our number one so we're gonna
carry on down the Milwaukee and try and
hop from shady spot to shady spot and
find hopefully Mississippi these
elephant sightings other than that
I'm also trying to see if we can pick up
anything on Team Ghana I know that some
of you saw him going over the dam wall
last night around 11 o'clock our time
and then this morning I think the guys
had a couple of tracks but there was
also lion activity and then we got
sidetracked with husana and with that
steamboat killed and ended up being from
tündi Scott was saying she was in a
little bit of a foul mood when he did
catch a quick glimpse of her and I have
a feeling that's because ting Ghanim
might have come near where her cub is I
mean she's just not ready for that yet
so it's possible that he's around here
summer although he does like to be our
last-minute leopard maybe he'll be our
last-minute lumber
now some of the areas because most of
the water holes have dried up here
except for the large dam I'm gonna take
four nice little browsing areas and then
we'll probably head over to chat with
them and see what spotting there maybe
we get a little bit of swimming I'll
ease that side now I'd be curious to
know what all of you are doing for New
Year's Eve I know some people like to
just take it easy and some people go on
I'll go all out so send those through
curious to know I think I'll be having a
little bit of apple juice with the crew
and then I'll probably be asleep by nine
o'clock maybe a little bit earlier and
then waking up to drive in 2018
all right just coming around the corner
here
we haven't done trees in a while and
these lead woods are looking very
beautiful
while we're repositioning to talk about
this very stationary tree let's head all
the way back up to the masai mara to
Ralph
let's see how his last Drive of 2017 is
going hopefully he's managed thanks Noel
and yes the lost game Drive of 2017
indeed and look at this landscape but
it's just it's mind-blowing in the front
we've got a mountain range which is just
behind the little town called telic and
in front of that and coming through now
we've got a big wall of rain that seems
that's coming towards us and we're
following along with the small river
line with a lot of trees running along
it but as I Drive through here I can't
help but reminisce and Phil Laak I mean
some of the areas that I've driven
around and frequented in Namibia because
the pots heading towards the
northwestern sections of Namibia are
very similar however the the feel to it
the climate is slightly different
because here it feels a lot more moist
not as dry as it is in maybe are not
quite as hot either and obviously with
the the amount of clouds that we have
here totally different to that in the
media because if
No maybe I only has this very rarely so
yeah we've just come across a small
aggregation of animals not just to have
a quick look because we've been driving
for quite a while and not seeing too
many animals and mana was actually
mentioning to me that it's looking quite
different because I think the last time
he was here it was full up with planes
game being zebra and wildebeest so a
little bit different at the moment where
all the animals have moved off down into
the Serengeti and so these are the
stragglers and the ones that have stayed
behind at lovely to see them out on the
plains nonetheless and still very
interesting to think that in I'm not too
long into the new year and we'll start
to see in the beginnings of the
migration once more but as we look out
there with the gazelle and the topi and
zebra happily walking through we're
going to be moving off soon and see what
else we can find along these immense
plains and while we do that let's send
you on back to Tyler and see how she's
getting on look at what we've got
brewing in the distance and I hope it
doesn't hit us but I hope it does pass
through the Maasai Mara because we
desperately need the rain but the winds
are howling down there that is picking
up so much dust and sort of swirling
around there was one bit of dust that's
died down and actually the variant was a
tornado in the distance it wasn't it was
just so much of it it is scary there's
lots of lightning and they'll be
torrential rain we are going to be hit
by this storm I just hope it doesn't
cause a flash flood and we are staying
at all of shaky of us here see that's
huge is just in the town of talaq and
the telic river will then rise quite a
bit and we could across over a bridge in
the tannic River which makes me a bit
nervous
okay well we're driving around here now
in almost in the area of Hummer cup
hoping to find some cheater of sorts I'm
gonna find a car hopefully they'll tell
me where exactly I need to go No
1:17
you'll get to see what she got you saw
on Christmas Day so if you're gonna
manage to find a little shady spot for
us to sit but also so that you can see
the beautiful blue sky with a little bit
of clouds and how vibrant green that
leaves are this LED wood tree and also
just the contrast with that with the
very light-colored grey bark so I'm
gonna let Ferg work his very wonderful
magic with all the angles he wants to go
out because this LED wood is just
beautiful all around I really enjoy all
the textures that that it involves as
well as the fact that it's such a long
living tree so we're coming to the end
of one year and the beginning of another
year and I think for a lot of us as we
do this we start to recollect our
thoughts and go oh my goodness gracious
I can't believe I'm this old and what
have I done with my life and that can
sometimes be a little bit I guess sad
about it but this tree actually makes me
quite happy and very hopeful it's a tree
that can live for over a thousand years
and it's just amazing it's a very hard
hard wood and the leaves are not very
palatable it's eaten sometimes when it's
a bit younger has a bit of spines on the
branches there and it not only protects
itself but it also does a lot of work
for the environment so as it starts
getting older parts of it hollow out and
after it has stopped growing and has
died off after hundreds and hundreds of
years it also then becomes a home for
many species so it's a home for species
whilst alive and then you can see there
one that's died and a home for species
whilst it's dead as well and then think
of all of the organisms that it allows
to carry on living far after it itself
has lived it just boggles my mind and
then once it falls over it takes about
another 50 years to decompose and that
decomposing then gives more organisms a
chance to live and evolve and then all
the nutrients go into the soil and then
create more habitat and more homes and
more food and resources for everything
around so this is my philosophical
movement for the game drive it's a
conserved tree inside of South Africa
but it's not a conserved tree in other
parts of Africa sub-saharan Africa
specifically so we talked a lot about
rhino poaching and we talked a lot about
elephant poaching and we talked about
how wild dogs are endangered and we
talked about
declining numbers of lions but we don't
necessarily talk about how the species
that make everything important so a tree
like this will be a place for a leopard
to put a kill in a tree like this will
give homes to birds that alarm call for
leopards walking past and that that
might save a kudu which then might have
another baby for another generation
going on it's a place for elephants to
rub their backs on after they've been in
the mud to help an itch and help take
parasites off or the same for a rhino or
a buffalo there are many many many
insects who will utilize the flowers
that are on this tree it's they mean I
could keep waffling on and on and on so
in other parts of Africa it's cut down
to make furniture because it takes so
long to grow the the species in general
is actually in decline as well so we
must also think about not just the big
and beautiful and wonderful and
charismatic but also something like this
gorgeous LED wood tree so I think you
all have heard my philosophical waffling
on for long enough time you'd like to
know are there any alien tree species in
Juma Thom as far as I know most of the
alien tree species have been taken out
so alien tree species would be something
like a Jacaranda tree or a blue gum also
known as eucalyptus we do have a few
plot species I've see prickly pears
every now and then and some coffee bowls
and a few things like that that are
alien invasives but to know not to not
too many trees this is pretty pretty
beautiful wild indigenous area that
we're in there's that texture it
actually reminds me of elephants the
texture of this and you can actually see
the rubbing from where an elephant's
been passed their thanks for all righty
it's starting to cool down slightly it
could be because we're city and shaheed
and there's a slight breeze it's clear
out there you can see more of that mud
from elephants coming in Pass so I think
what we'll do from here is we'll start
heading more east and then a little bit
more south and end up towards a chitwa
chitwa dem
in front of to lodge and see what's
moving species we can find for you so
we'll go from the flora to the fauna
alright onward and upward Ferg
[Music]
elana very good question so Ilana you're
14 years old and you're watching the
show right now I hope you're having a
very good time with it and you'd like to
know what is a subspecies so Ilana we
are Homo art we're humans but our
scientific name is homo sapien sapien
okay so basically what that means is
that there was a species called Homo
Sapien and then we are a species that
has branched off of that like a cousin
yeah
sohal gonna be
but this year and
[Music]
and Ralph is a subspecies a cousin of
that species so they can technically
interbreed so if we had any Homo sapiens
around not just Homo sapiens sapiens we
could technically interbreed with them
I'll give you another example just to
show the difference we get white rhino
and black rhino in in South Africa white
rhino and black rhino have different
species names so one white rhinos see
our cinema cinema I always mispronounced
that but that's the best I can do and
the black rhino is dye saris by cornice
so those are different genus and just
different species they're both rhinos
but they're not subspecies of either one
they cannot interbreed if that none of
that makes sense a lot of you must let
me know think about it and then send
through another question if you want me
to explain a little bit more because
this is I love this topic it's a
fascinating topic for me and I'm very
happy to carry on the conversation but
think on that and then let me know if
you want me to expand a little bit as we
carry on to the beautiful bushveld
I'm gonna come up onto a little bit of a
rise here and then you all will be able
to see what we're talking about with
hearing that thunder and the possible
rainstorm that's gonna come through in
the next couple of hours I just want to
move into a little bit of a gap so FERC
can show you properly what we're talking
about with this front coming in there we
go I think that works pretty well so on
our left hand side we have blue blue
blue sky hardly any clouds on the
right-hand side you can see the wall of
moisture and and cloud coming through I
believe the question was why in sabi
sands are Lions fewer in number than
leopard it's not the case that they're
fewer in number than leopard we just
happen to be seeing quite a lot of
leopard recently and one of the reasons
why we're seeing quite a lot of leopard
is the fact that the Lions are in
different parts of their territory but
continent-wide sub-saharan
continent-wide we don't know the full
numbers of leopards continent-wide
at all we do know roughly the number of
wild lions so there's less than 20,000
wild lions left there are one or two
reports that say it's closer to 30,000
but I'm more trusting and in the lower
number and for leopard we're not we're
not quite sure it could be a little bit
more than your population numbers tend
to peak and Valley in a similar fashion
almost in tandem not necessarily all the
way in tandem but almost in tandem as
opposed to a cheetah
who's our other big cat on the continent
so leopard and lions will peak and
cheetah will valley and then they'll go
like this across good question alright
so you could see that that beautiful
fronts that's pulling through here and
it's starting to get grey in the
background
I was top child that when when it's
pulling through and it
well they always laugh at me but I'm
actually watching these trees do it now
you can see on a snot jambo-claude with
this wisteria that's just in front of us
here you see how the leaves are showing
their backside because of the way the
winds blowing so instead of
sorry about that folks not sure what
happened but welcome back and look at
the lovely view that we have coming out
but we're getting a little bit worried
that we might be getting wet soon
because we seem to be getting surrounded
by the storm but will will continue
driving nonetheless and up for the best
we're aiming for that little light patch
in between the storm just hoping that
there's not too much rain in the middle
but that's our best bit so we're taking
our chances and racing for the middle
but we'll obviously stop if we see
anything exciting along the way we've
been looking at all the while for
cheetah
so it's still actually beautiful even
with the rain approaching we need it I
think a little bit dry at the moment but
a little bit of rain never hurt anyone
we'll just make driving a little bit
more difficult this seems to be quite a
bit more clay soils in this particular
area and these black cotton soils as
well so I can see that after the rain
could be a little bit slippery and slidy
get very interesting and test your 4x4
skills when to use your differential
lock in your low range you're just
trying to take the right Road which
leads us there are a lot of different
little to checks just to give you the
feel of how it is
so folks with this approaching storm
that you can see in front of us I'm
pretty sure it's half the reason as to
why we've got some problems behind the
scenes signal is getting a little bit
low but the tech guys are going to work
all over it and we're going to send you
to the mountain camp just for a little
while while I get the problem fixed
apologies for that short break in the
Safari everybody wrinkly there were some
technical issues but our wonderful tech
team both here and in the Mara have
resolved it somehow don't ask me how but
at least we are back on Safari now I've
made a decision to leave that area where
I was hoping tun Dee and her cub we're
going to poke their head out it's simply
so so thick in there that I don't think
it's worth our while sitting and waiting
I've also got this kind of sneaky
suspicion that she might be moving the
cub to kind of satellite dens if you
could call it that
temporary hideouts that are close to her
kills which is it a little bit premature
it's a bit premature for her to be doing
that but I mean it was also not
premature but it but out of the ordinary
that she took some kills back to Ward's
cabin the same thing happened this
morning she took which doesn't really we
made in there a little bit later this
evening once it's cooled off because
then more likely that two of them are
active right now it's still sort that
they are gonna be doing not a whole load
I'm guessing so I think it makes sense
for us to kind of drive around look
around see what else we can find in
return when it is a little bit cooler
what I would like to ask of you is to
just monitor the juma dam cam very
closely because there's a strong chance
that Tandy is going to go for a drink
after eating sternbuch all day and being
so hot so I'm sure she's gonna want to
quench your thirst and that is the
closest spots she's not too far from the
Jim Awards hole very good we are going
to send you off to Noelle with the
bachelor so sorry about those little
breakups we had there the weather is
stormy both ends of both of our sites
and them are in here so it does affect
the internet every now and then sorry
about that but in our travels we have
now found this a beautiful bottler just
sitting in the shade of a knob form tree
and you can really really see those
colors we were talking about this
morning as you know it's one of my
favorite Eagles and Scott's also been
getting some nice sightings of battle-ax
as well so sunny and we got interrupted
a little bit about your question about
what you think which animal has the most
sophisticated communication so I'm an
animal could be anything from an insect
to a reptile to a mammal to a bird so
I'm gonna choose a mammal species and
insect species that I think have pretty
sophisticated communication for me
that's going to be for a mammal
elephants and then for an insect it's
going to be honey bees so honey bees do
these really interesting dances and
figure Eight's
to show direction to the rest of the
hive as to where they've found a food
source and I think it's absolutely
incredible this this special little
dance that they do to denote direction
and and to pass on information and then
for elephants we were talking we've got
thunder that keeps coming in the
distance and the louder it gets I'm
gonna try and get it on camera for you
so you all can hear it it's a little bit
far off it's just a low low Rumble at
the moment almost like a train and the
distance going past so it's a little bit
too far for us to hear elephants can
hear that way before we can hear that
they also have infrasound of sonic
vibrations through their feet that can
go up to 60 kilometers 6-0 so they can
communicate amongst different herds over
quite far distances and there's there's
still a lot of study to be done on on
the the way that they vocalize I've
talked about my friend that's an
elephant research and I asked her the
other day for a bit of information on
that and she is saying that
need a bit more time to be able to the
anatomy the inside because they haven't
had a lot of chance to do a lot of work
on that I know there's a few places that
are doing some great studies so I'm
waiting for her for more updates and now
as we leave our battler and head more
towards Chitwood Dam let's head back up
to the masai mara where teyla has an
amazing surprise for you
apologize publicly for all the bumping
and bouncing that we've been doing this
afternoon but it's definitely been worth
it this is the view seen these boys
before right Archie has never seen the
Fast Five although also known as the
Musketeers and they're all together and
I chatted to another guide a little
while ago while we were trying to evade
the storm and he mentioned that earlier
on today well not actually not earlier
on recently they were trying to chase
around and catch a young zebra fall but
weren't successful so that's really good
news for us now there plenty plenty
animals around here from zebra to topi
to Impala Thomson's gazelle you name it
it is here the only thing I haven't seen
however some wildebeest but that's okay
they tend to you other things that
they'll eat and it's fantastic hunting
weather at the moment the clouds are
rolling in thick obviously we've been
watching the storm I'm a bit hesitant to
say whether we're going to get rained on
or not because I don't want to jinx us
and of course as you can hear it's
howling and then the wind must be
gusting at about 45 50 kilometers an
hour quite easily and they're quite far
away from us - we're gonna give these
boys lots of space Sharon you said
Taylor the cheetah Queen oh no no no
that stall Scottie the cheetah man of
Africa and it always will be
I'm however not the cheetah Queen I do
enjoy spending of at a time with him
that's for sure and I think we can
expect some exciting things this
afternoon now we just need these cheetah
2h closer and closer so the next set of
animals that I can see we are sitting in
a bit of a depression is kind of where
these cars are just behind them there's
a lugger this is a very popular like it
this is pretty much the exact same spot
where we had that interaction with the
Lions we have the male lions roaring
here we have the mating gerbils not too
far from here this is the hot spot this
is where it always happens so they're
gonna have to hit across that lugger
and then go across the other side and
they
from there they'll decide what they're
going to hunt but for now they're just
sitting there staring makes you want to
see where exactly their eyes are focus
but the fat in the middle of the open
area though I'm so sorry Nikki Nikki is
directing now the gremlins attacked Mara
too much I couldn't hear because the
wind is so strong I have my volume
turned up so loudly that I can still
hardly hear you
they're all staring in the same
direction and dreaming of a zebra I
think that's what they're hoping to
catch
Scottie says that I can be the cheetah
man of Africa's assistant thank you so
much it's like a researcher thanks Scott
I'll take that position no problem
I'm fast occur in chief and finding
insects for James and then the assistant
cheetah finder when Scott is not yet
very know his roles that I've got I'm
excited to see them I am going to be
very kind on tomorrow morning I'm going
to send Ralph in this direction so that
he can come and have a look at them and
then Archie and I will hopefully find
some other cheats in the area we might
go towards the talaq then and see if we
could find Malaika and two boys or in
Moniz daughters I don't know if they're
still hanging around there for big cat
week that I'm pretty sure Malaika was
still apart in that area so yeah so
that's kind of the plan the whole car is
rocking at the moment that's how windy
it is I feel like it's going to actually
take off and there's also a pony a big
pride alliance not too far away from
here I could see them in the very far
distance when we were driving in it was
about 250 cars of the cheetah and about
35 cars of the pride and lions
so there's lots and lots and lots of
animals around the side which will be
quite cool tomorrow morning to come and
explore I think a Ralph will have a lot
of fun around Jem
no I believe your rule saying thank you
very much for finding a fast five it's a
great is a great way into in the year
most certainly if they'd only just get
up and catch us one last meal can you
imagine if we have a hunt at 6:05
Eastern African time 2017 31st of
December that would be pretty epic that
would be good leaving 2017 with a bang
it really would but they're gonna have
to get on the move if they want to go
any further they haven't even popped
their heads up or change direction or
anything when we got sure we saw them
walking and then they can't be sat down
you know the cats love to just sit and
do nothing when I'm around I don't know
what it is an emailing manake jacket
which we think it's lucky we're not
actually sure we'll all have them on
today Archie has got his on too but
sadly no moving just yet for the cheetah
they're still just fast asleep
not prod cat mama you're wondering with
wind and the rain has got any advantage
or disadvantage to the cheetah hunting
it most certainly works as an advantage
and and the reason for this is that they
can move fairly quickly now and that the
same goes with lions and leopards and
any other predators without really
having to worry about making too much
noise they've got the wind muffle sound
for them and the rain you can imagine
when it's a torrential downpour gets in
your eyes but you can really concentrate
it's not nice it's all again it's loud
you can't hear so all these factors work
in the favor of the cheetah and
unfortunately not so much for the prey
species but the wind is swirling at the
moment it's not sort of going in one
definite direction you there's gusts
coming from all around the car so that
could kind of work against them if they
get too close and within a couple of
hundred meters and the wind changes and
the zebra and the topi and all the other
animals pick up on their scent
they're going to start panicking early
because the weather is like it is and
there might be a little bit on the weary
side and then the cheetah won't have as
good of a chance but if you look over
here just do the right thing here at all
but look at all the zebra from here oh
we're on
zebra not on a palm you're wondering
which is the dominant male within the
Cheetahs I haven't spent enough time yet
but everybody seems to think it's
d'Artagnan and d'Artagnan has been given
that name he's the only colored male
cheetah you may have seen there was one
cheetah with a collar around his neck
and so they said to him I've seen him
being bullied quite a bit and I'm saying
this the last time the last time I spend
some time with these boys there was one
cheetah that was definitely Keenan and
kept instigating the hunts there's the
topi not as well
a few youngsters sitting on the grass
it'll make a nice snack so it's hard to
say oh they're up there up there up
there that's exciting finally and but
they're constantly battling one another
you'll see them they bully each other
quite a bit and like I said I just
haven't spent enough time with him she
say exactly who it is but from what
everyone else says they think it's
d'Artagnan in a beautiful Chipettes
though so one is still I know he's got
up now he's on his way forward that's
that's d'Artagnan there that one aren't
they're stunning I'm just trying to
think I'm in a way for them to move
forward a little bit more before we make
our next move and head on down the road
to get a better position I do want to
try and jump in front of all the other
cars
you know we want to see if they're gonna
hunt we want to catch on all we need to
make the decision if they get too close
to the leg er do we zip around and wait
for them to cross the other side because
I have lost them in this exact same spot
it was to be fair pitch black it was
dark which is a standard ball but I
think we might have to think about that
now Julie are you wondering with a
coalition of five cheetah would they be
able to bring down a fully grown zebra
quite possibly they could indeed they
often take down fully grown wildebeest
and as every would obviously have a bit
more kick in it there's someone on
Safari enjoying the cheetah everybody
enjoy your Safari I see how they would
be able to and because there's no
wildebeest around maybe that's what
they're going to be going for or are
they're feeling a little bit lazy when I
say they're lazy I don't actually mean
they're lazy they're gonna take the
easiest opportunity to catch something
so if it means going for a zebra fall
and having to hunt again tomorrow they
don't look too thin then they're
probably going to do that they just
wanna catch something quick and easy oh
that's so cool I love it when they walk
like that and you kind of get the
skyline quite close to their heads it is
so so so beautiful not racing off just
yet though but making their way down to
that lager you know what we will do
though is I don't think we'll sit with a
crowd I think will be clever we know
where the food is we know what direction
they're going and once they get closer
to that like a we're gonna zip around
and get to the other side and wait for
them to cross even if we don't see them
for a little bit that's not a train
smash I honestly rather have them where
the action is going to happen
sitting and waiting and hoping that they
don't cross oh my and also the rain is
starting to starting to drizzle now
we've been waiting for it all afternoon
and wind is bringing it in quite quickly
very nice yeah let's go around because
these guys are gonna drive into oil all
those cars are over there and I'm not a
fan of crowding animals I don't know
what's on the other side though but I do
think that they hide something hard down
there so let's go across we are probably
gonna have to put our rain covers down
at some point which is going to be a
little bit of a nuisance especially if
these cats go on land
just keeping just keeping an eye on them
just to see what they're going to do for
the change okay I'm gonna let all these
other cars come through this crossing
and then we will do the same I'm gonna
send you down back to South Africa now
we're going from the fastest land mammal
in the world to one that is slightly
slower but could still escape your eyes
well they are slow but they did beat us
to the action if it was two tortoises
that were actually mating and they've
just disappeared off but that doesn't
matter because you have the musketeer
coalition on the move well done to
Taylor for getting you guys into the
right spot for that
and it looks like they almost
disappeared down a kind of burrow or a
hole into this large termite mound so
we're gonna just continue on sadly that
moment was missed there were a little
bit shy which I don't blame them they
were midway through the throes of
passion when we bumped we kind of
interrupted them and then I stopped
doing their business and then thought to
go and seek out some privacy and I
wonder if the Musketeers are going to go
after those zebra who knows Wow
time will tell for now though you're
gonna head off to Noel for a quick
update hello and you can a little bit
louder Ferg and I are debating whether
the rains actually gonna drop on us here
I can see where some of its falling far
to our south and west but I'm also
debating now we got an update about
husana that he moved away from his
termite mound this morning into the back
side of Chitwood dam so I was just off
on foot investigating and then I heard
some guinea fowls going so we're gonna
go investigate that now I really would
like to get some of this Thunder and if
there is lightning lightning on here we
were talking about the these big
beautiful cumulonimbus clouds that form
this sort of anvil shape and as they
form the anvil shape you get the
friction inside the cloud that creates
the lightning the thunder in a very
brief
small a little bit of a hippo noise
there now the rain that I can see
falling is not directly in front of us
it's actually just behind where this
dead tree is and you can see how the
color has come down and is the same to
the horizon as opposed to a little bit
to the left where you start to see more
of the different colored clouds that's
one of the ways you can tell where rains
fall and you can also smell it a little
bit and so it's possible because it's
been dry even though the rains been
building up that it's going to drop all
the moisture somewhere else and then
collect more moisture along the way and
then maybe drop on us or maybe it just
might keep going through
the thunder is getting louder so the
more we travel on looking for hasana
we will get the chance to hear it it's
one of my favorite sounds in the bush
okay we're gonna come back to the dam
itself I really just want to go
investigate those guinea fowl noises
that we had because there's a enough
moisture that's fallen I can't drive all
the way through these little pans at the
back I have to choose a side talk to
some of its and didn't pick up any
tracks or himself and then when the
guinea fowl were calling were the back
side so we're gonna make little to make
little loops around and see what we can
do it's also because the cloud covers
come through nicely it's cooled down
enough that if he feels like moving now
would be a good time and then with this
thunder coming through remember we
talked about with our cats here in
particular they don't necessarily really
like the heavy heavy rain it's just
possible that he's gonna start moving
using the Thunder even though it's still
quite light out to help with his hunting
and the wind that's picking up to help
with hunting and I think I think while
I'm busy doing this and looking around
Ralph has one of my favorite antelope
species in the whole world up in the
Masai Mara and I haven't seen it in a
very long time so let's go up to him so
you can see sub-saharan Africa's largest
antelope species is thank you look look
at this what we have unfolding here now
the tail has now been able to find the
cheetah but we've been able to find a
heavily heard of of real land that are
walking almost towards the storm and
we're starting to get rained on a little
bit but this lovely light at the moment
and remember these are the one of the
largest antelope that you get some of
them being over a thousand kilograms and
so that would probably be about 2,200
pounds which is a lot of white for an
antelope but what's also incredible
about them is that they can jump almost
as an agile is that how you can say that
they are very agile almost the same as
that of a kudu and they can jump now the
three meter
Finster's with the two-step run up and I
have actually witnessed this so for such
a big enter lab they're able to jump
very high in kudu and antelope are the
high jumpers of the bush and they're the
ones that we actually have to be very
careful of when there's national parks
or private game reserves bordering on
national roads or public roads because
when you drive they're not they can very
often be kudu an island on the road and
they get very confused by the lights
coming from the cars so that can very
often jump towards the light because
they don't really know what it is
they're confused and so you can have a
lot of car accidents with these animals
cuz sorry you're wondering if the horns
are used for anything else except
fighting
yes casada these are very short stubby
sharp horns and I'll use them to defend
themselves against any kind of predator
they're very adept at using those to
stab at any potential enemy and so it
can be a very good weapon for them very
similar to that of Oryx or him spoke
very straight but gemsbok being a lot
longer and thinner
whereas the eland a lot sicker and
sharper so but we're pretty sure gonna
be pretty soon and we've just been
trying to edge along it time to stay dry
but the wind is picking up and we've
seen a lot of lightning as well start
very ominous and I think we're gonna get
wet very soon
over there's back in the sunlight
there's the all escapement in the
background and so we've come quite a
distance during this morning and in the
early afternoon and
now Wendy you're wondering if clouds
produce thunder yes Wendy absolutely
this especially when you've got very
dense clouds like this because remember
lightning is formed through friction
within the particles of the clouds so as
there is more particles and more
friction and so you get lightning and
then that noise coming from lightning
being that of thunder so these big
clouds we're hearing quite a bit of
thunder and seeing the lightning it's a
very spectacular as the animals
I think braced themselves for the storm
that's coming and bracing himself I
think they just mentally get themselves
ready for a little bit of a miserable
time whereas the way we brace ourselves
is we're gonna have to batten down the
hatches on the land driver and get there
the sides up and and if it gets too
heavy we'll even have to put the front
down but we'll try our best to avoid the
worst of it at these type B and the
Ghazala in the background I don't really
have any way to go so they literally
grin and bear it as rain starts to fall
here in the Maasai Mara and the greater
Mara reserve but is beautiful I must say
even though it is a very ominous storm
coming I'm starting to get blown away
here but I wonder if Tyler's been able
to stay out of the storm but she still
got those cheetah and I think we need to
send you back to her
look out kita walking right past the car
I say Archie there like we own them we
don't they're free they're wild they're
coming right past us we've got ethics
picky sorry about that everybody
gremlins okay what I'm gonna do now is
we had a quick toast for you I don't
want to try to the wall of cars here so
we're gonna jump ahead now and I'm gonna
try and get you another view of them but
forget is a Dodge the vehicles they're
ever spray just because this could get
interesting you never use cheetah cats
has got paws
they'll come on towards us you're just
shuffling in my chair there's one coming
towards us yeah and maybe they're just
not sure what they're going to do it
that's thunder there's a big storm ahead
of us I don't know how that's going to
affect the feed of course like I said oh
do we are sorry about all the breakup
that we're having I'm not in a
particularly good signal area at the
moment and unfortunately can anybody
confirm we have an action broadcast
prepped please look how the posture of
these cheetahs starting to change let's
go
right yeah we're not gonna do an action
broadcast here everybody unfortunately I
want you to share it with a lot whole
world but that's one you can just enjoy
it then but please understand that
throughout this entire section that
we're in it's not very good signal
unfortunately so there is going to be
quite a bit of picture breaker but just
try and bear with us as this could get
very exciting with these cheetah like I
said you can see how they postures just
starting to change now from their
relaxed behavior earlier head lower than
the shoulders look no don't sit down
like that come on you guys are so close
inch closer and closer please maybe
someone will incur because they are
because they are inching their way
closer and closer towards a herd of
zebras so the ones behind them are not
the zebra that they're going for there's
a quite a long line of them and those
babies haven't seen these cheetah just
yet they have absolutely no idea
Archy are you ready our cheese never
found the cheetah hand before we're
definitely gonna have her attempt but I
think you should keep your eye on that
because at any second they can go I've
had the most amazing sightings with
these cheetah we're literally at you're
watching them and sat down like this and
the next minute one starts sprinting
let's see they're getting closer and
closer that probably about 150 meters
away from the zebra now and that's not
fast that's perfect
remember these cats do you need a bit of
time a bit of space to build up speed so
that they can charge and in and catch
something see and one just keeps punking
himself down another one it's gonna take
a seat that doesn't mean anything though
I wonder if they're looking for a fall
there's also lots of topi around
although a taupe you will give a cheetah
a run for its money because they're
quite quick and not to say that they
won't go for them because Scott's had an
amazing take down mister go ahead he
said you're apparently chanting and
going hunt hunt hunt hunt hunt hunt hunt
hunt hunt I think everybody sitting in
the siting is shouting that and of
course it is pretty spectacular what
we're witnessing to see such a large
coalition of cheetah it's not very
common so I'm going to be on the
Cheetahs side this time around they also
need to eat and also cheetah are not
doing so well obviously we're discussing
discussing their populations left in the
wild which is quite sad that there's
only a couple of thousand of them left
these days
however there's plenty of zebra
wildebeest topi and all those other
animals so it is important I remain very
wild dog even a hyena has got a bit of
statistic at hunting successful hunts
than these of cheetah or leopards or
lions so come on kitty cats you can do
it show us how it's done give Archie his
first hunt on the last day of 2017 that
couldn't go any better it really
couldn't I haven't seen again I haven't
seen any youngsters here they are
actually a lie there's bull bit to the
left you actually see the young one and
I wonder if that's what they're eyeing
heart
Thank You gang
Sydney are there to the Jimmy it's just
popped into the gap you know there's one
zebra that's much smaller than the
others here we go over to the right
that's a topi that's not the same
species of animal lover to the right
there we go
there's youngster maybe that's the one
they're looking for they could go now
they're close enough now they're about
maybe a hundred meters away from them
and also hear the thunder rumbling this
will be a bit scary to get stuck out in
a lightning storm I'm not going to be
enjoying that that's for sure that is
you're going to be terrifying
anything that's going to be a quick
storm either hopefully it just keeps
missing us we seem to have missed the
worst part of it so far did I speak too
soon should I have held my tongue I
never do that there's no falter with me
okay good boys keep moving keep moving
forward because the zebra also starting
to get away now
there's a big gap between the two herds
and I don't know no no I'm confused
the cheetah also do this though they
stop and they look they don't waste
their time they want to make sure that
the animal that they go after is going
to be the best possible chance of
catching something otherwise they end up
just wasting their energy the light is
also quite cool now it's very gloomy
just listening to the wind is some thing
bouncing at the back they look like some
Thompson's good oh I'm so sorry Nicky
whispered a question into my ear from
Joe I can hear what you're saying I also
got bad comes at the moment and the
Lighting's getting a bit hectic it's
very close the Lightning is actually
right over the top of our head right now
and I don't particularly feel very safe
now Judy are you wondering whether the
zebra would protect a Falls just kind of
like Buffalo
I'm so sorry we're having a bit of
technical difficulty with that amazing
cheetah's ID with Tayla hopefully we'll
be able to sort it out a little bit but
it seems as if you're getting some
excellent views regardless we went to go
investigator guinea fowl sounds and then
it turned into about ten different
species of birds and Ferg and I were
circling around this tree and it's not
the type of alarm calling you would get
for a leopard but there was definitely a
predator of a sort and we were thinking
that it was a snake and then also out
the bottom of the the Bush pops a really
beautiful African hawk eagle that it
obviously killed something there and all
the birds were mobbing him incessantly
and chased him off it was very cool
unfortunately it happened too quickly
for us to get on a camera but that's
alright it was a fun experience
nonetheless hopefully we'll be able to
repeat it for you at one at some point
now we've continued on with our loop
looking for a sauna I haven't picked up
tracks from where the guys were taught
no that's a hyena sorry I got really
excited with where the guys are talking
about he went into but I have a general
idea of where he is and so I think what
we're gonna do is just keep looping
around until he feels like popping his
little head out which hopefully should
be soon as the temperature has dropped
nicely so we're making another loop back
towards the dam to go check another
small little area and then hopefully
when we get to the dam there'll be some
activity with maybe the hippos or maybe
some elephants we'll just have to wait
and see Ferg's busy being my spotter at
the back here checking everywhere
Scott's I think from what I heard is up
nears biffle's hook so let's go back to
him and see what Carmen update he has
for us
well sounds like some exciting stuff
there with the Musketeers I must say I
am jealous pretty about the shaky signal
but at least they are moving and maybe
they'll move into better signal we've
just arrived at the Buffalo waterhole
and there's a very moody afternoon
unfolding here I can hear lots of
Thunder rambling off in the distance it
is to the south of us and usually the
bad weather comes from the north so
let's hope that it stays away and
doesn't ruin our BBQ plans for this
evening and the resident hippopotamus
just relaxing over here
and unfortunately the team up in the Mar
I've decided to power down their
vehicles because there's a lot of
lightning in the area and with them to
get fried the day before 2018 begins
fair enough
we thankfully don't have to do anything
of the sort just yet
but let's take a look to the south and
show you kind of what's happening out
there
so that's West and then now we're moving
towards the southern kind of view and
that's where the big dark blue mica Oh
was that a lightning bolt I think it may
have be you know just a little bit of a
flash I was looking away from the
monitor just caught it up the corner of
my eye
[Music]
wonderful what I'm thinking of slowly
starting to weave our way back to the
area where we saw tündi this morning
Nick you just say I've just jinx the bry
good well if we do have a plan B their
money there's a little area where a lot
of the juma staff almost have a dry run
n't and it's under a roof so we do have
access to their good spots
know which route should circuits go up
along the Buffalo cut line initially
there's one Road on Juma where we don't
get signal and that's the one down there
which is a pity because it's a beautiful
road called in yalla road north so we
won't go down there because then we'd
have to say goodbye to you immediately
I must say this stormy weather is
definitely bringing a nice cool
temperature so that's a plus scarlet
you'd like to know what is the most
popular meat to barbecue in South Africa
it's a tricky one but out hazard a guess
and say it's Bora forts yes Bora force
the reason being is this Bora votes or
farmer sausage which is essentially beef
sausage with a bunch of different spices
in it it's very very popular and it's
usually always incorporated in a
selection of meats that will be be
bribed you saw them go to a bright way
there's only one meat on the grill if
you do go to one like that you haven't
been to a proper bry there should be at
least three different types of meat
chicken kebabs or we call them societies
here some lamb chops or Phil at stake
and were a horse something something and
always Bravo's so I guess that's
probably one of the most popular and
common dishes that is grilled over the
coals here but you know whatever floats
your boat
guys get quite creative they do toasted
kind of sandwiches called bribery keys
just like bribe breads and you can get
rid creative with the kind of fillings
cheese tomato onion whatever you like
and you grill those over the cause those
are a good start and the meats are
endless you can do just about anything
on the Rye but your lamb chops pork
chops spareribs
multiple types of different flavored
burro wars fill its taker i'm steak
t-bone steaks you know it's just
never-ending
so it all comes down to the individual
and I think we're going to be doing some
seafood kebabs tonight for some of the
crew members who don't eat meats while
domestic meat yeah so those are plans
for this evening if any of you guys have
got anything exciting that you'd like to
share with us for your plans they do let
us know I'm wondering what Ralph and
Taylor are gonna get up to because
they've left the crew and I've got a
sneaky suspicion Taylor's wanting to
have a party in telic coun you did have
one a while back a few of you who've
been told about so I'm guessing that's a
plan other than that I can't understand
why she's decided to go across there
with her off now I mean of course they
could just have a party with you know
Ralph Taylor Manu and I think it's
Archie on camera with not even sure who
the cameramen are at the moments but the
four of em could have a partay at all of
shakey the accommodation over at that
side of the river but sadly I fear you
may not be able to ask them what they're
going to get up to because there's only
12 minutes left of their shift and I'm
guessing they are running for cover
so it's goodbye from them on behalf of
me and happy in years and you'll just
have to ask Taylor and Ralph tomorrow
morning exactly what went down
we thankfully I've got some
reinforcements to our skeleton Christmas
crew in the form of wildebeest aka
VM which is his real name and Louise
it's so very happy to have them back a
day early really hoping to see him fulla
an old male leopard at some point in
time the first time I ever saw him he
was walking down this road towards us
and it kind of actually just came off
this little termite mound
happy memories
okey-dokey now what be an epic epic
treat is that we could hopefully see
this tiny little leopard cub of Tunney's
before the New Year break so that's I'm
gonna head off and try and organize you
guys are gonna be heading off to know
what I'm not too sure what's going on
there
everyone friggin I have had to abandon
our husana search because there is
hectic lightning that's coming we're
gonna I can't stop driving because we
have this aerial at the back that allows
us to give signal off so you hook and
see yes and it is like a giant conductor
for a lightning storm that's why the
Mara had to power down because their
Lightning was too big we are trying to
move away from the lightning hopefully
we'll be able to give you some shots
when we get out of this area just of
that lightning and thunder that's coming
past it's a little bit tricky at the
moment I just want to get us over to
twin dam side so that we can not be as
close although this storm is now
gathering speed so worried with
something like this other than the fact
that you know we have to be careful of
the lightning just personally in our
vehicle either game drive vehicles you
don't have to worry as much because you
don't have that aerial that's at the
back but something that I worry about
with lightning like this with no rain
falling specifically right here we saw
rain falling to the south and the west
oh forgot one drop don't wish the rain
on us quite yet we have we have an hour
left an hour in a bit is that if
lightning strikes without the rain it
can start a bushfire and we're not we're
not saturated with moisture at the
moment here so it's it's difficult all
right we're gonna try maybe a little bit
of a pan shots as we're driving here
it'll be a bit easier for everyone to
kind of see what we're talking about and
we might just get lucky and get some
lightning in that shot I'm also hoping
that maybe now that we've had to abandon
we're hasana was maybe 10 Ghana pops up
for us or possibly we get something with
kochava we are in a little bit of a
bumpy road here so please excuse any
sort of vibrations that show through in
the camera I can actually smell you can
smell the nitrogen in the air from the
Lightning it's interesting with the
nitrogen cycle that aids in plant growth
a lot of plants need nitrogen they need
nitrogen and phosphorus in particular a
lot of the atmospheric nitrogen that
comes through and and gets into into the
air and the ground in the soil via
storms like this is very important just
as a
sort of side note for everybody it also
works the nitrogen sauce - [ __ ] psycho
Austin that was a huge thing of lighting
guys I'm sorry I'm gonna have to drive
very quickly away from where we are I
don't want to have to power down and
then it's just gotta be but yeah we need
to move so sorry for that to be Ferrari
so far away and then we've got another
vehicle that's none of us know all right
Nikki I think if I can't get away quick
enough we might have to power down for a
bit I'm gonna leave Ferg what do you
think should be powered down Nikki I
think we're gonna have to power down
guys I'm so sorry we're gonna have to
power down unfortunately it's too close
to us I'm not gonna be able to get away
quick enough so let's go to Scott and
then we're gonna try and get farther
away so that we can power back up and
carry on with everybody sorry
well seems like things are getting a bit
hectic out there not only in the Mara
but also fear the south of where we are
so Last Man Standing let's hope we make
it through this if not it's been real
[Music]
the riverbed that we are going to go
searching and it's just up ahead of us
here
Oh Juke Mason you are gonna be having a
turkey tomorrow so you busy prefer
preparing the stuffing for that sounds
good
very nice
thanks for letting us know
ah Mario's having full at stake on the
Bry spareribs and of course Buddha force
Maurya clearly knows what he's doing
when it comes to a bride those are three
good choices Mario what kind of a bratty
have that's the next question does it
have an adjustable grill a bra with an
adjustable grill I just find the use of
the coals more economic and your ability
to get whatever heat you really want by
the ability to lower them it's quite a
popular brand South Africa and I think
it's an American but I actually call the
weeba which is kind of like a round brow
with a lid which are great if you're
planning on using the lid and kind of
like doing a roast smoky chicken in
there but a lot of the time I found the
weave is a bit limiting because the girl
is in one place which means you can only
you know you only have a short window
period when the coals there are
temperature which is
that's frustrating for me when I'm
crying
thankfully tonight I will not be Brian
there is a younger better breyer than me
I tested him at our last bride and he
passed with flying colors his name's
Conrad is one of the new tech wizards
and he knows what he's doing he's also
but OCD which helps because when Brian
especially in in bulk you know you got
to keep turning the meat all the time
it's a full-on job and if you don't
you'll get one side that's a bit burnt
but Conrad knows how to avoid that Lauri
see and curious one sorry that I'm
making hungry I think I'm also making
myself hunger my mouths watering
Oh shame a lot of you guys in the states
don't have the most opportune weather
for prying at the moment so I think most
of your New Year's meals will be indoors
I don't think about that so that's not
fair we've been torturing you with the
thought of deliciously smoky flavored
Bry meat sorry
okay everyone needs to focus and
concentrate because you are getting into
the area where the major bolts of
lightening up their butt
we mustard sadly no there's a little
spot that I tripped into earlier which i
think is going to be a decent spot for
us to sit in wait
I made you like some of the tourists
that come out on safaris can kind of
cook food off in the bush and use the
wood from out in the bush generally when
tourists come out you're on holiday they
don't do anything and lift a finger
so they yes will be fed bride meat but
they're not going to be doing it
themselves and where any given Lodge
decides to get their wood is kind of
their matter of affairs
some people will bring wood and other
people will use the wood that's lying
out in the field it all just depends but
barbecues are very very common when you
come after lodges a lot of the lodges
will also put on quite a big spread of
wild venison so game meat animals that
have been hunted essentially from the
wild and then prepared and cooked so
what all depends on your camper the one
camp rise to it was quite a fancy camp
very expensive and there yeah I mean
bush breakfasts they'd be like ostrich
egg omelets and the bush prize would
have just about everything cooked over
the coals crayfish crocodile could do
did the long list of things even
sometimes have to steam prawns and a
bamboo steamer for sundowner snacks a
little bit over the top in my opinion
especially when you could be watching a
lion wake up we were forced by the
general manager to go and steam prawns
which I guess was a big reason why are
these belong very good
Marya you do have an adjustable grill
and on another level you've agreed that
Weaver's are not so good unless you're
roasting a chicken
as well as the fact that you don't like
charcoal or briquettes which a little
bit of a shortcut yes in a city that I
can understand the three don't really
have access to really good hardwood so I
guess if there's a will is where you can
always find some good hardwoods if need
be so basically just to keep you guys in
the loop of what happened this morning
or refill you in some way oft our arch
is where we got a little glimpse of
Tandy this female lipid and her cub it's
incredibly incredibly thick and if
they're lying behind a bushel in one of
the many little gullies that are in this
area we would never see them but our
only chances are if we kind of snoop
around a little bit and catch a tail
flicking or an ear twitching which may
give away their current position and
then we can try and work out how to
snipe a viewed but it's going to be
tricky so I'm confident that there's
nothing here
did I just feel a raindrop no
hello Joe you would like to know if the
Cape Buffalo's meet here in South Africa
taste anything like an American bison
and I don't have a clue I've actually
eaten neither of the two so I can't help
you there sadly with a lot of the wild
needs to be are getting a few raindrops
here this is a not a good sign well that
doesn't look like as much rain around us
[Music]
no bribe monsters just come in with the
report saying that the the bride is no
longer on the cards why not Nix
I mean I'm guessing it's because of the
weather but I don't think we doomed just
yet well at least we've got a back-up
plan at least the meat will be cooked
over the calls and yeah there are a few
raindrops falling which means we are
going to have to the cover up which
means you're going to have to probably
move a little bit out of this area it's
an area where we can hop out the vehicle
without the risk of a leopard attacking
us su tries to defend a cub
this is such unfortunate timing well we
do need rain this I mean to be honest
who cares about our Bry we can still
have a good time this evening regardless
of what happens but this area really
does need rains the more rain that falls
the better I did it could just wait half
an hour or so for the draft